je me trouve à la mode brebières sur le
terrain du centre de formation de la
fédération départementale des chasseurs
de la somme en compagnie de maxime
gombart chasseur depuis 29 ans bonjour
monsieur lombard je suppose que donc la
chasse ça fait partie de votre vie
depuis toujours l achat c'est
effectivement ça fait partie de ma vie
comme vous l'avez dit 29 ans donc de
permis et puis avant il ya aussi toutes
ces années où je ne chassait pas mais
j'accompagnais mon père mon grand père
sur le terrain donc on va dire plus de
40 ans d'expérience de terrain et de
gestion de des milieux nous qui avons
été élevés dans le monde rural on a été
élevé au milieu des desmarais au milieu
des forêts au milieu des plaines avec
comme activité la chasse mais y'a pas
que la chasse y aussi la pêche et toute
la gestion qui va autour au reproche
souvent les détracteurs de la jasse
disent qu'il ya des accidents de chasse
qui a des accidents mortels de là tous
les ans effectivement ce que vous vous
pensez que c'est quelque chose qui sur
lequel on peut encore travailler
on peut toujours travailler sur la
sécurité que ce soit la chasse sur la
route ou n'importe où la sécurité on
travaille dessus vous l'avais dit il ya
eu des accidents mortels y en a eu cinq
l'an dernier c'est toujours 5 de trop et
même un ce sera toujours un accident de
trop donc on va aller jeter un oeil aux
au siège de la fédération et bien
allons-y ces mots sont la maison
ossature
vous avez manifestée récemment c'est
quand même extrêmement rare de voir des
chasseurs dans la rue
oui effectivement c'est rare de voir les
chasseurs dans la rue ça prouve
effectivement que le ras-le-bol est là
la ruralité est attaqué de toutes parts
aujourd'hui il ya eu le monde agricole
qui s'est fait attaquer la chasse la
pêche
demain ça va être le monde de
l'équitation on voit bien que toutes les
activités de nature ou qui tourne autour
de l'animal sont attaqués alors on est
dans la rue aujourd'hui on l'a été en 89
on l'a été en 98 et s'il faut y
retourner on y retournera pour faire
voir aux gens que on est là qu'on existe
qu'on n'est pas 10 % de la population
dans la ruralité c'est un tout c'est un
ensemble c'est un mode de vie c'est une
culture quand j'étais à la manifestation
j'ai quand même vu qu'ils avaient des
discours contre les écolos non c'est pas
une critique contre l'écologie puisque
nous sommes les premiers écologistes de
france non c'est une critique contre
l'escroc logis oui mais pas contre
l'écologie l'écologie nous on en fait
tous les jours on gère les milieux on
gère les espèces on essaye de trouver
l'équilibré agro sylvo cynégétique mais
voilà on ne peut pas faire ça sans être
un minimum écologue nous sommes tous des
écologues alors faut pas confondre
écologistes et anti chasse c'est
complètement différent nous sommes des
écologistes et il ya les anti chasse en
face de nous
je vais vous présenter maintenant le
directeur na fédération de chasse de la
somme tirée delfosse qui est également
aussi un écrivain célèbre au niveau
national il ya un courant qui est pas
nouveau mais qui s'est beaucoup
développée ces dernières années qui ne
supportent plus cet acte de chasse la
société accepte plus l'image de la mort
or la mort ça fait partie de la vie -
quand j'étais gamin on sortait un lapin
dakhla pied on le tue et on dépossédant
de manger le dimanche c'était tout à
fait normal maintenant simple fait
d'avoir un chien en laisse ça va être
considérée comme une attaque sur
l'animal parce que chez ait en laisse ou
bien des canards qui sont attachées par
la patte quand on va la hutte je pense
qu'on marche sur la tête et à une
évolution
porté par une minorité qui n'est certes
pas représentatif mais qui quand même
commence à nous gonfler sérieusement
qu'on en a ras-le-bol
quant aux roses nos huttes brûlé qu'on
trouve nos voitures tags et qu'on se
fasse insulter si je vous suis c'est
devenu presque à la mode de dire du mal
des chasseurs bien sûr on peut dire du
mal de chasseurs sans problème à les
insulter n'importe qui de en menaçant de
mort ça va faire autre chose quoi merci
beaucoup pour votre témoignage
merci
qu'est ce que vous espérez du débat de
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous voudriez que cette question soit
abordée oui tout à fait il faut qu'on
prenne de plus en plus
position pour la protection de
l'environnement pour la biodiversité ça
c'est un fait il faut
il faut de surcroît que cette ruralité
soit mise en avant soit gérée et il nous
faut il faut absolument sortir la chasse
du ministère de l'environnement pour
créer absolument un ministère de la
réalité qui va gérer les territoires qui
va gérer la faune sauvage qui va gérer
les milieux naturels